ええ。
では、これから先に進むにあたり、
qubitは計算の基盤となる存在です
そして私たちが取り組める
世界の複雑な問題を解決するためのものです
では、その違いを理解していきましょう
そして、qubitの力がどこから来るのかを見ていきます
左側を見ると、
これは表現方法の一つで、このプレゼンを通して
この図を使っていきます
円と二つの点が見えます。点が北極にある場合、
それがゼロで、南極にある場合が一です
これが古典ビットの二つの状態です。一方、qubitは
量子の世界における情報の単位です
ここでは、この球を使って表します
球体はゼロでも一でもあります
この重ね合わせの状態を持つことができます
私たちには特別なトリックが使えます
この球体上で位置を取るだけでなく、
それぞれを小さな月のように
想像してください
球体の中にある月を回転させることができます
ここで分かるように、
下の球体が少し回転しています
だから青が少し見えています
そしてピンクも。さらに全部回すことができて、
これは百八十度の回転です
このように位相という概念があり、量子はそれを活かして
qubitに現れる三つの超能力を持っています
それは重ね合わせの力、
干渉の力、
そしてエンタングルメントの力です
では、それぞれ見ていきましょう。重ね合わせの原理は実は
とても直感的に理解できます
左側の星の場合、
北極がゼロ、南極が一です
この二つの状態を足すと、
ゼロと一を同時に持つ重ね合わせのqubitになります
ゼロと一が同時に、北極と
南極の両方に存在します。右の図も同じですが、
ここで少しトリックを使います
quantum gateを適用します
ここでやっていることを思い出してください
今度は変更を加えます、つまり
小さな月を回転させるんです
百度
八十度回転させると一になります
そのとき、ゼロ足す一をすると
重ね合わせの状態になりますが、
これは異なることに注目してください
左側のものはやはり
ゼロと一ですが、今は回転した状態になっています
この一の状態はとても強力で、
次の非常に興味深いことに活用できます。それが
干渉の原理です
これは古典的な
ビットの世界では使えない操作です。この例では
左側にゼロと一があり、プラス
先ほど作った新しい状態、
これもゼロと一ですが、
回転した月があります。これを行うと、
この二つの状態を干渉させることができ、
非常に興味深いことが起きます
一の状態が打ち消されて、
ゼロの状態だけが残ります
これは状態を干渉させたからです
次に考えられることは、
どれだけ多くの状態を作れるかということです
量子の美しい点は、指数関数的に
多くの状態を作れることです。五つの
qubitを持つシステムを見てみましょう。この場合、これらのqubitを
独立したqubitとして描いています。左側に見えているように、
ゼロと一があり、掛け合わされています。五つ
あるので、作れる状態の数は
この球体上に描かれた量子コンピューターで
二の
qubitの数乗になります。この場合は五なので、
二の五乗は三十二状態です
三十二個の小さな月が見えています
この場合、位相は組み込まれていないことに
注目してください。すべてピンクです。エンタングルメントという
この性質を量子の世界で使うことの強力な点は、
新しい状態を作れることです
右側に描かれているような状態です
ピンクと
青の組み合わせがあり、その状態は
これら五つのqubitの
独立した積として記述できません
この場合、三十二状態があるので、
これが示すことは、実はとても深い意味を持っています